welcome back uh today we're going to do
the lab for chapter 7 and this is the
chapter on uh nonlinear modeling and uh
additive
models okay as usual we'll do our inputs
at the top we won't dwell on the ones
that we've seen before we'll look at
some of the the new Imports um so one of
the new Imports is going to be from this
pyam Library that's the the the library
that we're going to use to fit
generalize additive models and then we
have um we're also going to talk about
blinds in this lab and we'll talk about
uh two different Transformers for Beast
blinds and natural splines from islp and
there are associated helpers for model
speec this BS and NS function we also
have a few utilities that we wrote to to
help with a pyan
package
okay so the lab starts off with a sort
of review of polinomial regression we
saw polinomial regression uh in chapter
3 already um but we're going to use that
to as it uh to compare that to splines
and later to to additive
models the data we're going to look at
is trying to predict uh wage I think
this is the Mid-Atlantic wage data we're
trying toct wage of um of workers as a
function of different attributes and
we're going to mostly look at uh uh wage
as a function of age uh there's also
going to be education level is another
feature there are several other features
you can find in the the documentation
okay so having fit uh polinomial
regression we're going to want to look
at the fit because one of the nice
things about additive models is for each
feature you can make a a plot of the
estimated effect for that variable so
we'll first took a take a look at the
fit for the using the polinomial
regression so um there's a bit of a bit
of a boilerplate code here to try and
make these plots that I'm not I'm not
going to dwell on we're going to make
use a function here uh in this lab
because we're going to fit me plot
several things as a function of age we
wrote a little function to make to make
our life a little bit easier so we're
going to change uh in the function what
the modeling um that is what in the fact
what the model spec is that's what we
call the basis and we'll evaluate the
basis um on this age DF this is a grid
of regular space values of age we can
use to make a plot um so let's just take
a look at at the fit of the fourth
degree
polinomial and uh We've also included um
error
bars one other thing about this plot of
note if you want to read the function
that produced it because we have we have
quite a few points to try and get a
sense of in the sky plot of density
we've added some uh opacity so an alpha
channel to the point so this is Alpha I
think 50% or 40% it gives some sense in
the scy plot of how many points are in
different regions I'm sad to say that
I'm on the beginning of the downward
curve of that wage plot
Jonathan well it doesn't go down too
critically right
yet okay
um so in building a a model like a
polinomial regression um you know we
often maybe want to determine the order
of of of of the of the regression model
one way we could we could do that is
using something like the validation
cross validation as we had seen
in uh in chapter 5 uh another way we
might do it is by looking at how how
what a statistical measure of how much
the fit improves as a function of of of
degree and we'll do something like this
later in the generalized additive model
where we compare fitting having no fit
for age not being in the model linear
and then with an additive function so
what we're doing here is we're using
this Anova LM function which is
something we saw in um chapter 3 to
compare the models as we make
increasingly we increase the degree of
the polinomial and just a quick takeaway
we're looking at um these F statistics a
large F statistic means uh the
transition from one model to the next is
a is a significant Improvement F
statistics are you know around one on
average so anything much bigger than one
is good evidence of a uh is evidence
that there's an improvement so we see
going from having no age to age linearly
as a big Improvement
and then uh quadratic quite a bit cubic
a little bit less and then the fourth
order doesn't seem to really add any add
anything to this
fit okay and just a note you can find
those fstatistics in the case we only
have a single feature can also be found
from fitting from the summarized table
but um let's move
on okay so that table we just saw before
looked at the effect of of changing the
degree of the degree we model age with
um and trying to pick you know when to
stop adding uh uh stop increasing the
degree we we're not limited to only
using age as a feature we can of course
do that with other features so here
we've used education which is a
categorical variable so we're allow
we're looking at the effect of age
allowing for education and we can do a
similar sort of construct a similar
table to see uh the Improvement of the
fit as we increase the complexity of the
age fit and we do again see a big
increase a big Improvement when we add
go to linear and still some improvement
when we go to quadratic we haven't gone
all the way to the fourth order degree
here okay
so we've looked now at how to how to
sort
of make a a flexible model of age for um
of wage is a function of age I should
say uh another thing we might consider
is instead of predicting the wage we
might just try and predict whether they
you know turn into binary problem to see
whether uh the the worker earns more
than 250,000 or not so we'll call these
uh the high earners um whether would
they earn more than 250,000 or not and
we can repeat the same process but
instead of using ordinary Lee squares
we're going to use uh logistic
regression and remember this is the glm
object from stats models and the family
is the binomial family that tells the
computer that it's a logistic
aggression so this is going to we can if
we fit this model and summarize it it
will look a lot like the linear
regression fit though now we're trying
to predict a binary outcome rather than
a linear outcome so we can similarly
make a plot of the estimated
effect and let's take a look at this
plot uh we have blue curve is the uh the
fourth order polinomial we fit with
standard error bars oh now my age
category looks much worse yes yes maybe
I spoke too soon about the de um so a
few comments about the plots so we don't
see the Scatter Plots uh that we did
when uh and that's because we've changed
the um the the y- axis here we're we're
trying to predict whether something you
know a binary outcome so we really have
cases that are zero and cases that are
one though here we've truncated the axis
to 0 2 just so that we can see this this
fit here so we've label the the points
up here these are the age values where
there's a tick here these are the age
values where we had a greater higher
nures and these are the wage values of
the lower nures and a similar device to
get a little um a little better
visualization is to add a little bit of
Jitter to the x-axis here to try and get
a sense of um how dense the ages are
because the ages are actually just
integer values so that you can't really
see anything by the T and notice how
wide the standard errors are on the
right hand part of the plot that usually
means there's very little data there
often you do get wide standard Aras at
the at the edge of the range but if
there's very little data then it gets
even wider yes and I'll just add one com
another another facet is if there if
there if everyone is a low wage earner
then there's that's another sense for
binary classification that there's low
data
yeah